talking their startup idea yes and good
like what are you going
it was leaders wasted that entire thing
people eat that I was like holy [ __ ]
what are you gonna say like what people
I try that something else happy about
that back in my like [ __ ] days I
tried I had a bag of pretzels Joker
[ __ ]
I had a bag of pretzels chips during
payday beers and it was a canine or for
some reason there was a lot of dogs in
there so there was a dog bowl next to
the snack area so like hey Nick
are you hungry in the night poor if I
meant to pour for you into the dog bowl
for him but the entire bag came out the
SH is wasted all those Nicky bar go pull
my phone out up tweets oh I forgot the
giveaway were you there when he
announced to us that he wanted to be
called tingle I couldn't stop laughing
at the idea of his name can't wait to
call him tingle tingle jingle email yep
marker no tingle marker abouts do myself
hi-oh hmm email I feel like we can read
our names cuz it's not like necessarily
like
I got it III also have really poor
eyesight oh yeah I take off my glasses
before the show so I can't read the name
um I mean I'd like to keep it there
because if you go any bigger they're
gonna disappear off this name fast rate
hi in high school sophomore year acted
in the crucible a familiar yeah that's a
salem witch trial thing yeah and I was
the character Ezekiel
[Music]
is this Twitter Ezekiel someone and I
was a person who came into her house and
attained and took what's-her-face - go
get hang my look her I had like three
lines but I killed him and I coming her
I come into the place he ruined I go I
smell a poppet goody Proctor it was like
I split open pudding talking points and
I still don't even know what pop it is
again the witch
yeah I thought it was like is it really
I thought it was like a like a prop or
like coming full like that object I
would I spell
and then and then the evidence of my
really great the last shot is who is
there getting hanged but you don't see
them often possibly on stage
the lies are dimming but my buddy and I
just did
Oh
settle real good story in the historical
context a poppet is a small figure of a
human being used in sorcery and
witchcraft but the British informal is
an enduring ly sweet or pretty child or
young girl they say empires that care
being a lot and I pop it yeah they're
talking about how she's pretty in that
and hope Bob a watch little bit of Moana
last night Milana Moana is karaoke did
you go read more I know I'm her dad we
should we should rent a private Kakariko
room soon [ __ ] built some Hey Jude
yeah I knew right when I was saying that
name
anyways like it I didn't finish it
singing it's a Disney movie it's some
music so away isn't baby Moana pretty
cute though when they're trying to the
dancer she's sprinting toward the ocean
to get a door can we talk about how
there's definitely like a Flight of the
Conchords song in the middle that
[ __ ] movie
well yeah what's his name Jermaine is
this is Jamaica but it wasn't worth item
8 it was written by lin-manuel Miranda
yeah
that was the best musical bit for sure
well yeah that's a 100% Rob favorite
well yeah but you suck flattened
cardboard yeah that's right I got that
five Australians like where's the car
New Zealanders we're like whisk ah
never mind me like a David Bowie music
video right like this how he sings yeah
so we should have a labyrinth it's good
watch seat the CG is awesome labyrinth
creeps me out
labyrinth oh well yes Knights Hussaini
and labyrinth and beatlejuice
beatlejuice feel justice alito man we
had like sociology other night okay
nobody say his name again because to
show up no
yes it's the idle games a creep what's
that other movie work what's the movie
raising dude what's the movie worried
where's that weird black leather suit
with the pointed ears
Jason Bateman the movie is Jason Bateman
he's talking about babby I'm trying to
be equally stupid thank you Ron
I like the better limb is thank you Ron
your knees always this much you
yeah that you should do but isn't his
monologue is so good he's like me go
damn well I find it really I'm looking I
like sit beside it
I've seen Iron Sam times he can fire
every single time I see it he says that
Beetlejuice oh I know Beetlejuice creeps
me out more than watch the monologue
it's the funniest movie The Exorcist uh
what are you you go here we go
you want to hear my qualifications at
will didn't Julian
it isn't real juice that like gross just
he's got like pink [ __ ] touching mole I
want to be that for Halloween be
something [ __ ] movie
I forgot that Daddy statement that
coffee thing handle people are already
talking about your handle coffee
we're daddy in my room for me forever
especially pray or sorry teh test I was
reading a tweet this
[Music]
just gonna what okay just on YouTube
okay
my coffee comes out of frame
I was really I was laughing this morning
at so it's like a text to series of
texts and was Johnny created a group
barbecue he goes a barbecue at my place
tomorrow
this next guy goes nice I can't wait for
a fat steak and a pair of ribs I'm the
guy who started the jaggis great any
vegans here it's their response yeah me
glad you asked smiley face next was
sarah has been removed from the
I wonder how long it would take someone
to figure out that they were removed
like why didn't hear anything about this
barbecue what did it I don't know if
I've ever been removed from a jet other
than like I have dramatically left a
chat for Maui effect and then had to ask
to be rieta jet
oh no I've done that and then someone
goes get your ass back here and they
pull me back into the chat it's like 20
people hey there yeah
it's weight talk what is a you guys were
plays a secret world nope
you guys play any mmo's did you okay I'm
going to talk about it you're all gonna
find something to talk about secret
world yeah cuz I know one thing about it
that's different
what want to save that for the show
Michael Michael they've made it free to
play when it was not
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
the lobby games box weekly video game
hangout here Wednesday mornings San
Francisco California I'm your host Mike
McCarty I'm here with Rob handler Kelly
foggy hello and bpop Brown otherwise
known as Peter Brown oh man I ruined it
if you're joining the YouTube or twitch
chats as always we have a chat up so
we're glad you can make it feel free to
talk about Pete's coffee he's been a
running joke lately what like for the
last few months now finally knocked it I
am you got me
uh I know empty we can we get a mop in
here a John Luke back there can we get a
mop in here I literally no I'm just
kidding I think Richard thinks there was
coughing it - yeah I got that no I you
Syria we this was yesterday as usual we
have a giveaway I forgot to bring it
into the room but it's a Deus Ex mankind
divided ps4 special edition it we kind
of thought it might be a good week cuz
we've had it in the nick margarita
Memorial Library our storeroom of games
but like with prey coming out this week
we figured I don't know it's an
immersive sim I don't really like man
kind of I'd it as much as I like prey
but we'll be giving that away so if you
follow a game spot-on you got Twitter or
if you don't go follow them retweet the
tweet about the giveaway that Shiva will
be putting in the twitch chat if you're
here but then later on the week they'll
pick a winner it's North America lonely
apologies to everybody outside North
America but yeah we'll pick someone
later in the week and you might win that
comes with Adam Jensen figured art book
and a steelbook case for Deus Ex mankind
divided a couple news items today Andrew
Wilson on an earnings call mmm
who said that EA would have liked to see
Andromeda scores higher but he said
there were a hundred reviews that were
80 or above that's great yeah but more
importantly he also said that the new IP
from Bioware which they've been kind of
talking about - specifics for a little
bit is pushed - between April of 2018
and March I don't know if I wrote this
down right of March 2019 that's
definitely a 9 that doesn't make sense
why would so it got delayed a little bit
he said it has nothing to do with
Andromeda
here's any idea what it could be I mean
it's a new IP so we have no idea we have
no idea maybe maybe it's a jet Empire
remake which isn't a new IP but that's
what I want because think it's a racing
game of some sort from Bioware
puzzle game there's been there have
there been a racing RPG crossovers car
battler Joe did you make that up no
that's a real thing that's a real thing
did you explain this game to me
please I've never actually played it
it's a Game Boy Advance game I think
that in Vault it was like an anime RPG
but based on like a racing series so
racing was somehow involved I think I
tweeted about Road Rash yesterday on the
n64 the best version probably good tweet
screw that ya know 60 weight the 64
version of Road Rash is better than the
Sega Genesis original why do I do you
want me going depth I don't know because
I never I've never played the Sega
Genesis that's a really good reason
that's how I make most my comparisons or
Joe this is car battler Joe yeah I
actually don't know if there's any
racing in here but it has the word car
in it and I'm pretty sure it's not
repeat I meant like you're a car in here
it's an RPG
there are fighting games where you play
as a car that's weird oh there's a
dating sim where you date tanks but
they're girls tanker oh thanks are all
women they are the women are
anthropomorphic representation of tanks
what are the men is pretty interesting
are the men is just you and you get to
pick which one you want to date Oh
gotcha some tank dating simulator that's
what's uncool I want a helicopter dating
simulator helicopters are hot
what kind of helicopter would you date a
be 67 cool umm yeah anyway and then also
in other news it's not a real helicopter
ah 2012 the secret world MMO if you
played that it's relaunching as a
free-to-play game called secret world
legends from a fun fun calm yes I don't
set Funko that's not right on June 26th
so if you never got the chance play that
you play I don't have people that play a
lot of MMOs and they liked secret world
a lot I mean I don't play a lot of FF
and the Mo's but it's more this suburban
horror tale and the secret world is kind
of talking about this [ __ ] going on over
the surface this kind of buff
what was he doing mornings am i right
did you do motion capture for that was
that you
um so for some reason when you said
secret world in my head I was imagining
secret garden so this is very different
very different but yeah this is more
about vampires and werewolves and
suburban was it his head just exploded
somehow yeah so that'll be out June 26th
it's free-to-play game isn't like the
Old Republic free-to-play now mm-hmm
a lot of memos go that route after a
while I guess after their subscription
numbers fall off but uh and then another
game that's coming out soon on May 26 is
rhyme yeah job parades yeah um if you
haven't seen it yet if you're watching
now you can go watch Jess MacDonald in
our Australia office she got to play
about an hour of it I believe or
something around that but she talked
about it how different influences she
really liked the Last Guardian shadow
Colossus eco I mean I know the art
design is kind of winwaker ish I would
say like the Game Capture my interest
because it looked sort of winwaker
there's like it sort of looks like the
witness art style to just really
colorful but then with that a Last
Guardian sort of kid exploring with an
animal companion sort of thing that I
find very charming she compared it to
the witness in the way that it's kind of
like mist this mysterious island that
you're trying to kind of decipher but
yeah you haven't in sense of that's not
rhyme neither is that oh this is just
the intro where she's talking about how
she played oh okay gotcha yeah yeah I
was looking for something more
refreshing that uh uh cuz ya personas
like a hundred hours and she wants
something a little quieter looks really
yeah it's uh yes she made the Last
Guardian comparison cuz I don't know for
most again you have that little right
there you have that Fox character with
you um I don't know if you're have to
climb on this thing too and if it's not
gonna listen to you half the time and I
don't know I'm just dissing The Last
Guardian I don't really like that game
well it's feel free to defend it Pete is
this gonna be on the switch just on the
switch at all or not yes yes and they
just announced a I think originally you
would have had to pay $40 like $10 extra
on the switch but they tackle version
Nintendo just announced today that you
don't they down the price for that you
few hours ago or something it kind of
makes sense out I'm just glad this games
coming out cuz yeah now it's for ps4
right exclusively like three
years ago yeah and then it was sort of
like well the studio is sort of like
losing its relationship with Sony and
who knows who controls the IP but hey
here we are
GUP Xu Ryan the twitch chat regular
GameSpot viewer was just asking how long
was in development I believe that's
literally years yeah like you oh it was
I thought he was just joking around
about the Last Guardian comparison no it
really was I don't think it was nine
years
is it like definitely years and they
just taking their time or were there
kind of like well I think there were
disputes over what the game should have
been maybe I mean that that was kind of
my understanding with the deal with Sony
was that like and this is all just me
gleaning from what I've heard online you
know it's like there was some sort of
like disagreement where they couldn't
figure out how they wanted to ship this
game and that kind of fell apart
mm-hmm-hmm I mean that's yeah I don't
know for certain this is super close
yeah May 26th I think the next one also
injustice to is May 16th and then we
need to slow the H down with all these
games I'm still playing every game I
started this year except for a resonable
7 in Zelda I have not finished
it's pretty depressing yeah I'm in the
same boat just like really finished
Zelda though I guess not I just the DLC
is coming out soon I'm just never gonna
finish another game ever feels like
resonable 7 I want to replay every game
I did beat I want to replay a lot of
games there's too many uh yeah and then
I did want to talk about strafe more in
depth because Michael hi um his review
went up he gave it eight out of ten a
great out of ten yes yes and uh he liked
it a lot obviously but I played it
yesterday Rob you and I were kind of
playing it during our lunch breaks yeah
I play it for like hour and half two
hours yeah I feel like I got the gist of
it pretty quickly which is not to say
the squeakiest cherub sorry I'm not
trying to direct you what's the for
people who aren't familiar cause it's
sort of like not super on everybody's
radar what's like the elevator pitch
it's like styled after like early 90s PC
first-person shooters and it puts you in
these procedurally generated levels
where you might find some weapons that
are super helpful or just a standard
fare of weapons and you have to fight
these enemies as you explore the map and
look for sort of the
each like level has like a few
components sort of like a Super Mario
World
yeah we have like world one when one one
one two and three that kind of thing
it's also pretty difficult it's very
difficult I saw from a lot of reviews
that went up they said that they didn't
finish it Michael was saying he read a
bunch reviews I don't think I think but
they're pretty honest about their saying
it's just really hard we still like that
I know like IGN I don't think got the
chance to finish it before embargo any
places
Michael was like here late like yeah how
is this game did it gets it like it's
not about marathoning because it takes
so long it's just like you know you get
to like the end of the game and you die
you start back at the beginning yeah
yeah it's a roguelike so you've got a
you know kind of pick yourself back up
and try it again which can be tough for
some people myself included yeah like
for me I was like you know as shown I
could throw those oh really oh I did
that how do you that a couple times cos
amma was like getting spares
oh my haven't seen that guy yet uh and
that's things like everytime you know as
you progress you get hit with you know
some new enemy type and it was the ones
that were like on the ceilings i would
spit out like homing of offense that
shudos sorry waste you and then they
have that asset on the ground that's
right so when you kill them they spill
acid everywhere basically and that stuff
takes if you step on it takes away a lot
of damage so in this game you are just
reliant on moving incredibly fast and
that is just one of those things you get
the attack on but all right now I got
changed my whole play style it's just
yeah you're gonna dialogue right that's
a little buggy to like when I was
playing today I was noticing some like
pieces of models were like stretching
across the screen like an environment
I'm a guy that I killed like there was a
polygon that was like I won but also
like I picked up a rocket launcher at
one point and I found the ground and I
was all right cool I don't want to use
that yet I want to save it so I used my
weapon wheel to go to a different weapon
I went back to the rocket launcher and
it was in the state where when you run
out of ammo you can only just toss the
weapon right you can't melee with it I
thought you could melee throw it or
melee sure I couldn't get back to
actually using and actually used it I
had I had ten rounds they left for it
and it was like the dude I had I had def
was that straight for was Michael just
comparing because this is his video
review right oh no this is all strafe
they apparently there's
somes at Wolfenstein no but this is a
like a moshing Amash to a superhot right
here like yeah a weapon that lets you
sense time yeah he was talk about Easter
eggs than what we just saw was that like
gameboy style
uh I don't know yeah yeah one thing
Michael had a complaint about and you
raised this to me as well Pete and I
didn't think about it until I played
again and I agree is the weapons don't
have much hath to them I know it's a PC
keyboard game or a mouse and keyboard
focus game although it is on ps4 but the
weapons I mean you fire and it's not
much impact on the enemies you get I
mean well [ __ ] that's the worst thing to
prove my point but there's a lot of
impact there but I guess it's kind of
blow Civ right yes you're using shock on
our machine gun it feels like using a
peashooter kind of yeah yeah because
there are a decent mount of weapons more
than I thought yeah that those three
true from the beginning ones like this
more precise laser rifle if you're kind
of really good with a mouse which I'm
not and then there's a shotgun and like
a SMG that also its secondary fire is a
few grenades but yeah then you pick up
these power weapons and you find those
uh it showed it earlier it looked like
that little what was that thing from big
fortune tellers or Zhu Zoar knows ULA's
Ghostbusters butts or whatever his name
was you put the gun in and he like it
looks like a fortune-telling booth and
then you you age and you you dance on
this keyboard with no I'm just talking
about big now oh yeah it upgrade your
weapons and you can like I saw you were
using the double-barrel shotgun after a
while Rob not that super hot one but the
original one that you upgraded yesterday
yeah that was that was neat I I mean I
just found things a little too like
vague or ambiguous it's like hard to
gauge like what ammo types or or maybe
even the currency like I I didn't find
it very like heavy-handed on the
tutorial aspect were like I couldn't
like see something on the ground and
know exactly what it was
currency is especially like yeah it's a
pin point so it's like I mean only
playing two hours I was like kind of or
hour an half I'm just like trying to
figure out like what exactly am I
looking for or striving for oh sorry you
know yeah it but it again like this is
such a fast-paced game it's kind of hard
to soak in and like experiment when
you're going up to a currency booth and
why
doors open more guys come in like you
it's it's tough to like get a grasp it's
also the trouble with when you're
sticking to like a classic ascetic
because it can be harder to visually
indicate what something is when you are
trying to make it look old if that makes
sense
right like sometimes it could just be
hard to go some bug's chitter-chatter
chitter-chatter
Oh God gee God you guys watched the
movie trailer for it mmm from the what
you're all still 96 Ted shorts it's if
you've seen the trailer from God it was
like a year or two ago uh it's very much
in the same vein I'm just like you know
VHS 80s retro but like hardcore heavy
gory bowtie on oh my god there's this
one where he stabs a FBI agent with a
skateboard into his stomach and rips out
his intestine sweet and then like his
friend jumps friend jumps on the
skateboard and takes off therefore
pulling out feet and feet of intestines
like Nora Lee and that's the same style
of that actually transfers into the game
where it's like if you guys do the
tutorial at all do you see that isn't
that that doctor woman telling you it
was in the video review as well um it's
pretty funny and you see that in the
game right like you go through like I
want to say it's like a area where
you're then able to put your scraps to
use and stuff like that and there's like
a series of sign just like well they're
those gnarly like go for it like I don't
know it's it's got as the style of humor
that like an 80s skateboarder stoner
would have which is which is nice and I
it's kind of funny to read that stuff
yeah I might be like hobo a shotgun vibe
or turbo kid yeah even specifically that
intestine thing yeah yeah right what is
he doing turbo kid I forget cuz he took
an actually strangle is he strangle
something yeah it's an exercise bike in
the knee they like they put a like a
hook in his stomach and grab his
intestines and then they let they're
interrogating him and then he gives them
the info they want and then they still
do it anyway hmm and it's such like you
were describing the noise it's just this
grinding noise well the worst part about
all that like
ridiculous violence is that as the sky's
intestines are being ripped out he's
like oh no like I would not want to be
alive for any of that but a date
leadership always like okay movie where
the do's got was it Tropic Thunder I
think I always like she's like yeah back
in yeah oh yeah I was like a fake war
scene in the Vietnam War scene yeah that
movies on Netflix now you should watch
it what one thing I really did want to
say about strafe is um like quake was
one of the first games I ever played um
and like quake and doom or two of the
first games i remember playing and so
like this is a game that like I want to
play anyway because I have that
nostalgia but do you think it has like
it has enough going for it for somebody
who maybe doesn't have that because
that's that's what I from what I've seen
in play like that's not I don't have a
sense for that yet right I think you
guys have played more than I have that
was definitely my main draws the classic
shooter feel to it not necessarily the
rogue like elements because it's very
much a robe like it's not no blight like
you don't carry any progression between
right when you restart I don't think I
don't know if every time I've died I
didn't have much progression but yeah uh
it definitely feels like I like it more
because it's paying homage to those yeah
that's the sense of everything but it's
also kind of it's a nice contrast what
I've been playing lately it's just very
fast-paced the soundtrack itself I just
the first steam soundtrack I bought like
seven dollars if you like that kind of
hardcore outrun kind of synth eighty
stuff I don't know how to describing it
well but you should check it out because
it's really good I've been listening to
it throughout the day now just talk
about hard-driving tempo like they're
just like a heavy sense yeah it's really
good fun I'm really good it's my toy
tree the artist I don't know if that's a
it's a look I'm up on look that artist
up on Spotify um but yeah Michael Hyams
review is up you can go read it at
GameSpot it's an 8 out of 10 if you want
to read more about it
I don't know any final thoughts you can
play more uh yeah it's actually been
nice to play in the morning it like kind
of wakes me up a little bit real just
get coffee you know I get in early a
little bit uh I'm booted up you get in
really early honestly that's like a good
way putting it is like I this isn't a
game that I would play for hours on end
but like it's for sure just a nice like
little like refresh like I mentioned to
you like there's no way I would want to
play it as a mobile game but like if
there was a way to play like on a bus
like it'd be a fun like like our you
have some kind of fuses to play it in
which to play it in short increments
basically yeah like yeah it's not sit
down and scream at it for but you super
need a mouse you super need a mouse 100%
yeah that's where it doesn't necessarily
convert I do not want to play this with
dual analog um lumps come on YouTube was
asking when he played sweet name they
were asking when they played it uh a
demo earlier it felt really floaty is
that the case I think so still the key
like I mean I'm not yeah you skate kind
of when you walk if you had y mean
you're yeah I mean you're encouraged to
move hence the name of the game but if
you are not super adept with keyboard
controls if you're playing on mouse
keyboard I don't I don't know haven't
played it on ps4 but it looks equally
floaty I was having trouble like with
smaller platforming sections where you
had to jump onto a catwalk to progress
took me a few times
my aside from like overwatch my mouse
and keyboard skills are kind of out of
date recently but Eric green on YouTube
is asking if sorry did you have yeah no
I mean it's definitely like there is uh
your acceleration is insane right like
you're always at what feels to be from
either zero to ten so yes you're like
constantly like micromanaging like all
of your WASD keys like and as far as
like the jumping or flowing that you
know there's no that ties into momentum
and like being grounded on the ground
like on the floor like there's no head
Bob or I don't think there's lack of it
it doesn't seem like there's any as I'm
trying to say it but um yeah I I could
kind of feel that but it's not like it
doesn't like deter from the game at all
yeah going that's more of the point
right yeah yeah I mean I was jumping a
lot over the smaller enemies if either
like I had no room behind me going back
to what uh Callie was asking Eric green
at Billy was kind of asking is the
roguelike nature enough if you're not
into those classic shooters did you was
that pulling if it's kind of hard to
tell because I haven't gotten that far
into the game yet I don't love
so that's actually something I I don't
know I don't really think about it too
much I just kind of want to like get
into the strafe action and I'm not
worried so much about progression yeah
like I said it's just like a thing that
like energizes me real glad I'm so happy
to use it for that it is a kind of a
strength of it being a robe like right
you're not worried you're not like
overthinking it cuz that's that's what I
like about roguelikes is sometimes when
I'm playing anything that has any sort
of progression system I overthink it
like even with prey I was like sitting
at a thing yesterday like panicking and
then somebody ought to come over and be
like it's okay you can come back to it
you're gonna be fine um so I like that
because I'm not overthinking it and this
isn't a game you can overthink like you
shouldn't be thinking too hard so I
think that suits it well um but I don't
know if you don't like roguelikes and
it's kind of like ooh well luck you're
gonna dial out yeah weird question I
realized this but would you guys want it
on the switch I'm not saying I don't
there's been no talk of bringing it to
the switch but in terms of these
bite-sized games don't laugh I have a
real reason for ask this we were talking
about it we were saying like I was like
the analog it would be tough to play on
a switch I would get killed even more
but I would like to have that for those
like quick sessions when I know I'm
probably gonna die in like 40 minutes so
maybe I'll play it on the bus or
something
I still can't play that switch on the
bus no I saw like barn I'm joking barest
or because motion say no because it's
just like I don't know I got a sec
Spencer be certified a toy it's like
here's my new toy everyone like oh yeah
there's this anything like I mean if
you've ever been on uni like anything
and everything go wrong do not ya know I
know I always don't want that to ever
happen why not pull the switch out the
dirty eight nah what you got there you a
dollar no but I have your joke but I
have a have a switch I don't he wouldn't
even know what that is
uh but I don't know I would like it for
those I know you're saying you're
booting up the morning went one you get
into work or when you wake up like in
bed under under you like your PC comes
out of the ceiling and you start playing
great very much like the trailer like it
always just like invested when I get
into the office I don't think I'd want
to play it on switch no no no it feels
going back to that being sort of an
homage it feels like right at home I'm
see that's what I was gonna say it's
like that kind of back to the floating
movement even like that kind of movement
make sense on PC that's personally what
I am used to and how the movement and
mechanics I'm used to when I'm playing
something on PC like that so it just
makes sense on switch I'd probably like
mess it up way more and then actually
get frustrated or tap over to Zelda or
yeah or just be like look play Mario
Kart with this ten minute bus ride yeah
um
speaking more about the switch I don't
know Pete you put something up recently
that was like Wii U exclusives we want
to see it was a very thoughtful and well
researched gallery you interviewed on
Miyamoto for it right
imagine a simple gallery cuz it was like
okay there are a lot of Wii U games that
are great that maybe people missed and
why not have him on swish because Mario
Kart 8 is a really good example of a
game that was even super popular when it
came out and yet is more popular now
which is great to see for a great game
uh yeah so I just like ran down you know
ten exclusives to make it sound like a
gallery and a gallery it was and here we
are talking about it
what we you games do you want on social
angle mm Bayonetta 2 okay because I
never played Bayonetta 2 and I have an
excuse now I don't well I wasn't really
too much into the Wii U unfortunately
but what about the idea of like port
begging right or like or like just
saying like well now there's a platform
we like so we should get these games
over here I cuz I'm of the mind where
it's like I would personally like to
play these but do I want devs taking up
time that could be spent on new games
report this stuff that's yeah that's
kind of a that's winwaker again then
yeah well yeah I know I was gonna say I
will play Wind Waker once again if they
released it in HD on the switch I I mean
going back to what you said Mike though
it's like I didn't how do we you all
right still have a Wii U I didn't play
it that often because it just wasn't a
great system and so there's games that I
want to play that just didn't feel right
and so like Tokyo Mirage sessions is a
game that I think I would actually
finally get into on switch because I
would have more time and this is
winwaker which is so much spleen okay
explain Tokyo Mirage sessions to me
because I saw gameplay last year when it
to years ago really two years ago
so is it um did I get I get we can help
each other
that's something Rob's favorite game
let's tag-team this so it's it's an RPG
set in Tokyo set in Tokyo um it's more
talking to Madison Ellie about this cuz
talking about games to play after
persona 5 and he was like yeah it's like
in a similar vein but just way happier
um
his teens aren't really as far as I
understand dealing with a lot of angst
and turmoil and they're not frying
they're not unhappy - Tokyo Mirage
sessions is happier than persona yeah
yeah yeah yeah why is that such a hearty
laugh do you see what they were just
doing every fight like in those big
arenas is like a pop concert I mean it
revolves around entertainment it
revolves it's yeah it's it's a definite
light-hearted game especially compared
to persona 5 yeah Felipe I'd are on
twitch apology from bitching her name
says all the special package with
winwaker Twilight Princess and Skyward
Sword skull HD collection yeah that'd be
awesome
I will be good so I've never played sky
red sword but I think I would actually
play it if it were on sesh he there's
mixed Justin hey while just replaying it
recently before breath of the wild came
out I liked Skyward Sword the first time
I played it and then I played it more
and I I know the running joke is to like
not like Navi cuz she annoys you in
Ocarina but fee she tells you how to
complete puzzles like straight up when
you walk into a room and you start you
know you see a new room in a dungeon in
Zelda your first you're just trying to
gain some sort of spatial awareness and
figuring out what's going on in the room
she'll stop you before you can even do
that and say oh it looks like those
electric balls will open this door if
you can get it across that why are you
telling this I can figure it out no
idiot
I love the battles outside that little
area that we were linked was going
around like that little circular like
walkway down there there are some really
cool moments in this game but but by and
large it's not that special I I just
feel like a bad Zelda fan for not having
played it um like I want to play it for
my own sense of completion
and I think the reason I just want like
the reason switch is more appealing to
me than any of the previous platforms
for some of these games that aren't
immediately attractive to me
because I hate the art style actually of
this game a lot is just the switch being
portable and me being nearsighted I can
actually bring things closer to me and I
don't know why but that's a big draw for
me and I know that's lame as hell but um
it actually has improved my experience
like with Zelda I only play at handheld
for example so I think with some of
these games that I missed on Wii you
were before that I would really enjoy on
switch this is bringing back good
memories yeah he's got like the worst
opening and a Zelda game really ring it
is when you talk about V spelling things
out for you this game tutorial eyes is
like have you ever played a video game
before we're going to teach you what it
means to move using a controller and
like every everything is just so it's
like 2 hours of tutorials for you can
really get into the game like proper
like the adventure
I like the flying with the loft wings
yeah it still time on Skyward Sword
right yeah
yeah she doesn't say there's some bad
openings in Zelda in general I was yeah
I was gonna say like worse than the
super slow Twilight Princess sequence
worst yeah yeah yeah cuz Twilight
Princess isn't as much I mean it
tutorial eise's things but most of that
is just like setting up the really
somber melancholic tone of the game yes
which I afterwards I like princess
really dark Skyward Sword feels like my
first Elda adventure that kind of thing
yeah but uh
in terms of other Wii U games do you
have any utility I was gonna say
thinking about the switch and maybe how
like how Mario Kart was so cool and
honestly like getting into a game on my
couch playing Mario Kart online is like
super quick and I'd be excited to see
another multiplayer title maybe it's I'm
thinking about how does anyone play like
jackbox on yeah I played it yet on this
which no not on the switch but I know
jack but um I'm just thinking about how
that game like what's the game in that
the draw 'fl no it's one where you're
guessing people
guess who's who was it fib
oh no oh not David's another one I I
wish I remembered oh I'm work not guess
is a guess peonage no that's not good
either retry yes the right answer like
the most popular answer in chat we'll
get to it yeah you tryna you trying to
say it's what like raise your hand if
you uh ever like go to the doctor last
month and area nosh isn't it the spy-1
gonna get a guess who sure anyways my
point being I would like to see like a
Mario Party hit that would maybe
incorporate that kind of idea of like
hide your screen or some like that like
and maybe like I'm at a private type of
like game mode or something like that I
don't know that there's something to be
said about like in the office here like
people who do happen to have like other
friends with switches like that mobile
aspect people it was a bad friend with
switches that rules me out I think
that'd be cool
I like to see more multiplayer titles
making its way um you would mention it's
kind of it I think you were saying it's
a stretch because it's coming out
there's the sequel coming out but what
is the open-world when you're on that
the Giants fakin it
thank you Xenoblade crossing okay
connect that is the GRP do thank you no
faking it was the jack box game
Xenoblade is the game you're talking of
like the moniker an ex cross cross
depending on your region X or cross or X
cross it'll Japan its cross yeah I
believe like pronoun x chrono x turn
across
yeah [ __ ] kpop do so xenoblade
chronicles you would like that on the
Wii U yeah I like that game a lot and I
first I just watch people miss it I I
hate this guy so much well I can see why
oh my god like his scar I hate him so so
much this game has horrible voice acting
which is like one of its worst that
sucks but like as for an open-world like
RPG it's really really good and I really
like the combat it's very it's a good
sort of progression from the original
Xenoblade Chronicles on the Wii what
happens like 50 60 hours into this game
you're setting this huge world with
things that seem way too big
but then you get in mechs yeah and have
is like so late in this again yeah the
whole game and your whole perspective on
the world changes and suddenly these
monsters that are towering
above you are like more your size and
it's just like a it's such a cool
late-game expansion to what you've been
doing at that song pool I remember you
reviewing that game and you were pretty
torn or not torn but I remember you like
saying you're trying to explain here
like yet later on it becomes this whole
different game almost yeah yeah and I
kind of wish it it got to that point
earlier I don't know didn't you guys
play Xenogears no musician RPG so you
get mechs in that game similarly you
don't get them until kind of far in but
it's not as far I feel like they were
trying to go for a similar thing here
anyway yeah so they're coming out with
Xenoblade Chronicles to the original
Xenoblade Chronicles did not involve
mechs so I don't expect to see those in
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 so you know in
that sense if there are no mechs in the
new one having this there might be a
nice complement to the Xenoblade verse
switch um philanthropy on YouTube was
just saying if you're talking about this
game you thought that soundtrack that's
been janka right yeah yeah okay
that's what I thought but he'd been
djenka he does a lot of our behind the
scenes stuff for GameSpot publishing and
whatnot he was saying yet talk about the
soundtrack do you remember the
soundtrack does stand out no it doesn't
Bend I'm sorry I let you down
was it a Gaston or even pseudo joint
yeah awful figure 8 yeah I feel like we
have to mention smash yeah this for sure
I mean that's pretty obvious yeah that
has to happen mm-hmm um I mean splatoon
2 is coming out but you were talking
about like another kind of multiplayer
thing but for sure like just playing
Mario Kart online yeah party stuff party
stuff you're not one to switch what I
was poorly trying to say was like just
something you know they have such a
really unique device like I could just
see people thinking outside the box
maybe like a jack box way that was
horrible so like I can go right yeah you
can touch ways of just incorporating
that oh my god Wow
um I really she know what you're like
red
anyway I think Super Mario maker is is
almost yeah oh yeah for sure absolutely
would that work as well without the
stylus you've got major stylus scale the
one what got your stylus away from
Sultan but it's a lie the nature's I
understand why you did that but the way
I thought you're flipping me is by the
way you angled your hand was a little um
yeah you do have nature stylus um I just
want to do yeah I mean this
conversations just wanting yeah I just
want all these new games to come out
like we talked about this on the lobby a
few months ago like what franchises we
want to actually see come back not games
ported and just Metro is the obvious one
a new smash would be great who knows
when that would happen
do we need any swish yeah why what it
lost you want what like see what we
didn't need smash on the wheel new Mario
Cart
well no we're not but mmm what is that
argument okay I would like to say that
it would be a port of smash on Wii U
because that takes soccer I like at
least six years for each smash so it's
not any new but I think he's I think he
realizes that and is still arguing for a
new I will argue anything if I feel like
I would win the argument I don't need
backup from I don't need to back on my
points I don't need to justify myself to
you and your smelly stylist no not your
you oh don't worry my argument if I am
was weird
uh any other somebody's sage they want
System Shock Don Mattrick on YouTube oh
no System Shock so we're gonna come to
switch um f zero would be dank I love
SEO
that's how Captain Falcon was say it
Danks all right I think we talked enough
about we people have been coming here
for prey I think a lot of people are
wondering why we want to talk about
dishonored to not a lot of people but
for those who don't know pray is made by
Arkane Studios who also made dishonor
dishonor to as well as like going way
back today arcs fate Alice Dark Messiah
Might and Magic worked on a bunch of
cancelled games as well but yeah pray is
has been out since Friday and because
it's Bethesda publisher with their
review policy that didn't give us codes
until the day before a few hours so two
more
hüseyin in the UK has been playing it
his review progress is up his review
will be up soon right
very soon it's scored review full review
people on an editorial we're looking at
it earlier so that'll be up we've all
played it I've played it rather
extensively Rob you played a little bit
more last night cally you started
yesterday I think people go I played a
little bit on ps4 last week and then I
started this morning on PC for reasons
we shall talk about I'm sure yeah but we
did want to talk about dishonor too
because those these games are they're
similar in that they're immersive Sims
right that's a really geeky esoteric
term for you know these games that put
you in a world where they're it's got
its own rules and physics this backstory
that exists whether you want to look
into it or not they also kind of usually
encourage player experimentation with
these like overlapping pretty complex
systems dishonored it was magic powers
uh arcs fate Alice same thing Dark
Messiah same thing but Dishonored was
more of a stealth game action hybrid so
you could choose to go stealth or hybrid
and that's not the case with pray praise
is very much its own beast once you get
into more specifics than my new show of
the thing but the dishonor to was
probably the most apt comparison to make
because I came out last year in October
I believe and I really like this honor -
and tomorrow's review pray really like
to sign her - he was one of the ones
along with me and feeler people who were
pushing up our game of the year list I
did want to talk about the differences
between those two because of those
reasons I'm just mentioning uh did you
guys all play dishonored - yeah
definitely
yeah you you played the no powers mode
or deed enough not mode it's on a mobile
but you chose the no outsider powers
playthrough when he offers unto you yeah
and it's it's a cool comparison because
with dishonored is so much more self and
I think mainly due to the fact that the
AI was so much more responsive to you
and the environment so like I consider
playing pray and you know it you know
yet feels very much like a arcane game
when you when you load up pray and
you're experimenting so I'm throwing
boxes I'm throwing objects into rooms
while crouched to learn saying a
phantom to to be distracted so I can
walk by a doorway or something and
there's no response with that like the
Phantom's in the AI in general seem to
be just separated in that respect which
isn't a bad thing it's just like you're
not you're not getting the benefit of
like distracting or confusing AI like
they just seem to be either like Patrol
or kill and it's one of the two things I
mean I think is a different hook yeah
yeah comparing these games for me is a
matter of like how your interaction is
like how important that is to the
experience where dishonor - it's sort of
like sky's the limit
like with what you the powers you have
of what you can do with them I haven't
encountered and I haven't heard any
examples of things here where you're
actually combining a lot of different
things like quickly on the fly to do
interesting surprising stuff but I think
that is the pitch for Dishonored right
series is is making that happen if
you're not doing the stealth route where
stealth is equally treated you know with
with care and respect I mean this this
definitely seems to be more of the
immersive exploration game right yeah
and resource management is much bigger
than anything I mean it's important to
SONET and much of a much of the reason
you thought more about the structure of
the games right because dishonored is
these nine there's a nine
I think it's nine discrete missions
dishonor to is nine discrete missions
Dishonored one was also these separate
missions you could jump into and then
spend your time there these separate
sandboxes whereas this is all one
contiguous world that interlocks and
although there are parts that you won't
get into until later because of some
story beats you could still freely
explore it but yeah in the sense that
this is much more resource management
survival game whereas you know like we
said dishonours that hybrid that you
could still choose to go either way or
my favorite way to play dishonored even
though I love stealth games and I did
the no kills no alert playthrough which
is probably my favorite way I'm at the
first way I played it my favorite way to
play Dishonored 2 was to actually my
like mix the two approaches and this
game seems like you have to mix you
don't have to it gives you the freedom
to not but in terms of resource
management there are some abilities that
I really like over the others you have
these three human tree
right here security engineer scientist
and then you know like the thing that's
been widely publicized and it's not
really spoilers that you can start
researching aliens much like you did in
Bioshock when you were using you were
researching the splicers a camera and
then you get alien abilities another
three trees which are based on telepathy
energy and morphing I believe if I'm not
mistaken but yea this game is much more
resource management Rob you like are
liking that yeah definitely I
I do enjoy finding every nook and cranny
and just it's that process of like it
very much minecraft right where you just
load up your inventory and you make it
back to your base or your recycler and
you offload there's this there's a crazy
gratification you get from that I don't
know I did I love doing that it's like
tidying up
you know like cleaning your room which I
should have been doing last night mom's
gonna be so pissed
hi Robert get off that get off the
Nintendo get off your pray good I suck
that's for your mom ski job straining
all right head okay but uh so happy this
parts good it's kind of spoiler actually
um but I the the yeah I mean we said it
to death I feel like about the mimics I
think they're pretty neat I know one of
the complaints that other people are
having is like you know what point is it
just do you enjoy the unsettling nature
of entering a room and the musical cue
that comes in or you do not like it yeah
and I I have been liking it and but I
totally understand that like really high
piercing reading oh but it's jump-scare
and it's meant to do just that but I
agree with the Semin that it's like
alright I wasn't even looking at it and
you're and you're scaring me and at what
point does that get kind of like tedious
and and unsettling and I found this is
just a personal tip is that you can turn
down the music and I'll order to like
50% hmm and that significantly made
those those moments less frustrating
yeah like and that is gonna bleed my
next thing is I sorry I cut you off not
like the the sound mixing in this game I
think is a problem mm-hmm when it came
to like you you have your main January
or Alex talking to you and your hat
you're having an intercom in the room
playing the intercom will be
significantly louder than the actual
narrative dialogue and that happened
often and I found that very jarring
frustrating just weird mix of things
words like a what I call they're just
those box a fly around or they name name
those things
operators operators there was one mobile
area where like most areas where I had
those guys flying around there like two
halls down and they're so overpowering
loud and I'm having a phone call I don't
know if you guys have had that issue at
all but that was frustrating to me I
just I guess one of the bugs that people
have been having I don't know I also
heard about like characters talking over
each other yeah I haven't encountered
that yet but obviously that's a problem
um because if you want to know what's
going on you can't hear it I probably
will end up turning the sound down
because it's really frustrating when you
enter a room and like I don't even know
that the mimic is there yet or I suspect
that a mimic might be there and then
there's the sound I'm like oh I guess
now I'm ready to look for it like I'd be
better if it was I don't know if you're
not even looking at it and it appears
and then you get that sound it just
doesn't make sense to me I don't know I
don't like it as jarring I do like the
GAMEOVER although later on I want to get
into my overall impressions yeah because
I think it's pretty wide ranging across
all of GameSpot staff but later on I
don't know I it's tough spoilers in this
game are more mechanical like [ __ ] you
can do experiment experimenting so I
want to talk to but much about it but
you find the hunters bolt caster if
you've been watching gameplay it's this
toy bolt caster that shoots foam darts
it seems useless at first but then there
are I'm finding more and more uses for
it but there is an enemy later on that's
attracted to movement and so I start
using the bolt caster more against them
and to distract them but if some every
once in a while last night and I found
that problems were persisting more if I
like went into rest mode overnight and
then turn it back on again later as
opposed to closing out the application
going back in sometimes I come in I
might just be
my imagination I thought the audio
problems were worse after that but you
shoot the bolt casting when the foam
darts hit a wall makes a squeaky sound
and it got me so phony Oh Bros over here
we can talk about this uh small sounds
annoy me if they're consistent and kind
of uh like like you make a lot of noise
you see necks mean you infuriate me oh
you're not just joking I'm joking
slurping coffee
I hate they don't let you talk certain
like guttural kind of noises
I hate mouth noises disorder in candy in
the afternoon oh stop don't even make it
don't you make that son yeah okay I'm
with you I know you can hear me take the
bowl caster squeaking would keep
repeating until I reloaded a pretty
prior safe I can't even talk because
it's annoying me so much thinking about
it and I was in my room at home and I
paused it and it continued when I went
to the kitchen and I came back I was
like I'm gonna blow my face off if it
keeps happening and I almost did but no
I didn't I just reload of safe but apart
from those complaints I am really liking
prey I love this game I'm really liking
this game um and I don't know and I got
to the point where I'm experimenting
more powers and it really is a game that
you have to if you don't want to
experiment with different powers I think
you can go through the game like a
specific way more than in Dishonored
dishonored I think actually kind of
force you to use different powers to get
through this game is kind of giving you
the choice if you want to in my opinion
I've been doing I was texting Rob the
other night and again I don't I get too
into mechanical spoilers but like
figuring out these situations you know
there's not many environmental puzzles
mapped out as and it would be in a Zelda
game but there are these situational
puzzles that kind of arise based on what
powers you have so these two turrets
were at the end of a hallway and I
couldn't throw an EMP charge that far to
disrupt them and I couldn't I'd have
much ammo so I couldn't shoot them and I
want to save ammo regardless but they
recognized that I've been getting more
alien powers and they recognized that
the type in DNA and me which the in the
persistent threat the nightmare which is
an alien starts chasing you when you
have a lot of alien DNA but also the
system the station's start to turn on
you but so I put an EMP charge next to
me on the ground and then I mimic that
and then rolled up behind turrets
because they didn't recognize and that's
really super cool
and I and that it's I'm really you have
to go out of your way to try to combine
on these powers I think you could get
through without them like I know I it
doesn't kind of force you to as much as
I think dishonored did but this game
gives you the freedom I think to do that
and I've been doing that more I think
you're liking more for the survival
aspects though yeah I think so like I
had just touching on like the powers of
the morphing right I can morph into this
Cup
again like I haven't played enough to
like make like a strong opinion but I
was you know you see it in the trailers
and and highlights of this game where
it's like oh here's like a teller slit
in a room I know I can get in this room
if I'm small as a cup and it's like okay
well next I know I'm spending a lot of
time trying to like make a series of
steps to jump up as a cup into it and I
found the object handling and movement
like pretty janky and that was just
something where I was like a kind of
Obama from you if they're gonna give me
this power and implying that I can get
into any kind of small nickel cranny and
I wasn't able to do that in this moment
was like when I will and this in this
moment last night I spent like probably
like 10 50 minutes I was like I won't my
doing this is dumb like I there there
are going to be more heavy handed clear
applications of like okay this is an
area that can roll into and maybe hope
hopefully the morphing tree spans outs
was like a higher jump or obviously more
objects or different types of en't
whatever it is on analyst spoil anything
but yeah yeah I like no I like having
like kind of janky solutions to problems
like I like having the option to like
not elegantly solve something and I like
that that is a possibility in this game
at least from what I've played I love it
when there's not always an elegant way
to solve something but you like just
barely figure it out and so I'm liking
the potential for that but I I think one
thing that is really irritating me so
far and I'm at the beginning is a
fighting mimics and how quickly they
move versus how slowly I move yeah is
like it's super frustrating really like
it makes me feel like I'm really bad at
the game or something when I don't
I'm particularly bad at games and so I'm
like trying to figure out how to
properly shoot them with the glue cannon
to slow them down so I can hit them when
you're out of it and then you've got a
wrench in that yes lonen accurate and
that becomes very cumbersome uh and
again going back to my earlier point
like I like that I don't feel
overpowered necessarily like I like that
I can struggle with things but that
particular combination of movement has
been bugging me a little bit well if you
preorder they gift you a shotgun at the
beginning of the game so that was your
mistake you didn't pre-order I would I
would HIGHLY discourage using that so
it's the shotgun the thing the game
gives oh yeah I would highly if you know
I thought that's the thing you're
supposed to play your own way right yeah
I have it your way
no not I play all you want but I think
the game would be better I didn't get a
shock and I'm really liking that I I
cranked my sensitivity I didn't have as
much of a problem but you played on PC
and said you liked it better so yeah
this is what I was nasty well so what
I'm liking better is not necessarily the
control it's it's not the practical
application of the controls
it's the physicality of playing on a
mouse and a keyboard versus a controller
because maybe I have more control over
the camera but I still I still find that
wrench combat and those those mimics to
be immediately annoying and honestly
detracting from my ability to to want to
explore because it is just this shrill
thing that is just kind of like really
shocking and when I just have my wrench
like I have to get close enough to this
thing to hit it and it takes like three
four hits and in those three four hits
I'm getting struck as well and there's
really no way to get around that
so I find it to be punishing me for
engaging in something that I can't avoid
mm-hmm and that doesn't feel fun you
know it's interesting like you're it's
nice to hear that you're having a good
experience on the ps4 because yeah I had
to crank my sensitivity but actually
after strafe because I was playing last
night I kept thinking like man if I had
to play this on a controller I would
lose my mind and the instance is the
phantoms where they just they'll do the
warp - hmm and next you know they're
behind you just that alone and there
they hit really hard right like you have
to spin around and I was doing like very
twitchy high sensitive moves with the
mouse and keyboard
you're saying that uh men tears no the
land on a controller but switching from
a shotgun or sorry glue gun to a wrench
with a controller that would get really
frustrating I least in my eyes wide
angle he'll try no it's super easy yeah
oh it is yeah okay cause like for a
keyboard it's like one two like I'm just
like instantly a you get you a radial
dial you can pull up pause the action
yeah it's like a magic weapon wheel okay
weird is compared I guess I guess I
guess what I'm saying is that would be a
better even pausing the game like you
don't have to with like the PC I find
that much more if we just develop a
rhythm where it's like glue like I it
doesn't I don't I know that a lot of
games do the slow down mechanic of like
the wheel whatever it is but there's
there was something about like quickly
like switching to any of these weapons
and developing that rhythm that I really
would want opposed to like any kind of
like controller I don't know I would pop
I would probably map weapon changing to
my mouse wheel if I was on computer
that's me though mmm you can actually
just get yeah yeah you can yeah well I'm
playing on xbox cuz we only had Xbox
code yeah and that's going fine yeah but
even even like inventory management in
the menu like yeah that's a perfect
example no right that's obviously much
easier with the mouse right or even even
the touch decode keypads in the game oh
yeah no that's the cool thing actually
this numpad on it oh you can do that or
I've been having to use the the e or
whatever key to interact
I just been walking up to it and then
you just point your cursor and I just do
numpad it's actually pretty fun yeah
that's the one thing is on console I'll
like go up to a computer and then I'll
try to interact with it and I'll forget
like it's a two-step process so I'll end
up just jumping in front of the computer
and oh yeah idiot yeah I like computer
mapping like button selection on these
keypads to the d-pad which is what I
would prefer to use to scroll through
them you actually have to use the analog
stick to look at the individual button
yeah so it works the way a cursor would
work and that's so weird interacting
with and you do I really so to talk more
positively because there are things I do
like I really like going through emails
I think that that sounds very boring but
I like looking into a very small piece
of somebody's
conversation and trying to figure out
what is going on what the context is and
so I do a lot of interaction with
computers and so just that input I'm
noticing that a lot more because that's
something I do frequently but I do like
you know those environmental puzzles of
like solving like oh I need to figure
out where somebody kept their password
or like where a code for this safe is
how do I find that in this environment
like how do I glean that information so
I'm liking all of that like I like the
atmosphere and I like I really like kind
of storytelling that you opt into like
you don't have to read those emails but
it's something like it slows me down a
lot but I really enjoy it yeah but I do
look I feel like an idiot when I jump in
front of the computer I do that with
fallout 4 or actually kind of similar in
fallout 3 you actually pressed you had
to select to go into and look into a
locker and then you would after that you
press the button again to take items but
and for you just have to look at it and
then you could take stuff and still and
fallout for him when I play it
occasionally I'm still doing the same
thing and jumping and looking like an
idiot but yeah the you can talk about
the game's storytelling I really really
like its approach to letting me find my
own story and kind of you know I'm
coming in and I'm telling talk about
these powers I use but I'm also saying
like jean-luc beat the game jake is
pretty far in and we're all talking
we're like oh should I even know that
was a quest I ended up finding this
before I even got the beginning of that
quest and then Jake will say like oh I
didn't even get this and I went through
that area I thought I scoured it and
then I'll find an email that mentions is
one person then I'll find another email
that mentions that person from a
different perspective and then I'll find
that person's like a note that they had
on them that you know says this and then
you'll go into this crew computer and
you know you'll see there's no life
signs so you know they're dead there's a
few people that are still alive on the
station but you'll see that the dead and
you can track their corpse through that
and that becomes a side quest you do
because you know that they have like
this fabrication plan so you can make
this weapon in the future indefinitely
and then you'll find out that there was
a feud between these two like her and
her or him and him because he stole his
like work and took credit for it and
then you'll find his body and find
something on it that really is another
side of the story
and you two are saying that the emails
and stuff does feel kind of ham-fisted
in some of it feels superfluous to
writing itself I agree with that I don't
think the some of the emails are
actually really the emails the notes
some of the like the books you read I
love the lore of this game as if Kennedy
wasn't the assassination attempt failed
yeah like I've been reading all the
books I can find I found one on
linguistics and I got all excited yeah
like I just I nerd out for stuff like
that in any game so obviously that's
something I'm going to latch on to with
this game like if Kennedy survived and
is if he survived or if there was never
even an assassination attempt I think
it's your teeth if he survived yes and
then the space race essentially the
Soviets and America would kind of
combine forces eventually rather than
the arms race and everything and then
you know like it just accelerated this
idea of exploration in space and
everything but then it gets really
sinister but I like piecing this stuff
together I'm not in it for the sense of
a traditional narrative I'm in it kind
of trying to find my own and piece these
things together and you know like
finding out that this person has a
shotgun in their room and I didn't get
the shotgun to like 15 hours in which
everybody else is like I took like two
and I still like errantly there's one
hidden like really close to the start of
the game like the first room yeah it's
in the yeah it is it's in a one of the
first big areas I think you're talking
about yeah I didn't go there because I
kind of kind of got overwhelmed you walk
into the lobby and it's just you can go
wherever right immediately yeah what was
kind of odd actually is I think when we
play the preview or the demo you know
there the linear based nature of the
first hour is like you're getting into
that first room and you're going to
follow the same path you get the glue
gun and the demo it was like the shotgun
was right after and somebody was saying
here that they actually did change that
change that yeah it was interesting um
yeah no I mean I actually have come
around on the emails to stuff because
you kind of eventually know the you kind
of know what you're getting into with
some of these emails right like alright
this is kind of nonsense I'm looking for
something in this case yeah like a
familiar name or some like that like
I've been getting better at that and
have been enjoying it yeah like the
there's like some book that seems really
interesting like some like things like a
comic book from Sierra t'v but it's like
it's like pulp sci-fi you're talking
about yeah but what's neat is you know
like you think of the JFK
like conspiracy and everything but like
soon after that there was another
conspiracy right like that is just how
things are the way they are cessation
all these little stories you guys are
talking about something really
interesting it's just I feel so put off
by the combat early on that it's like
and then when I see the emails that are
more mundane and they're not as
interesting it's like well then why do i
subject' myself to this sort of combat
to get to that point like I think I
don't know maybe the game could have
been better if it spent more time
letting you just feel enveloped in its
world rather than threatened on a
regular basis on a constant basis like I
hear you I hear you but I think I think
there's a hump to be said where it's
like eventually and I was getting there
last night where it was becoming easier
and I'm more confident and not as like
tinted by the environment because of the
powers and the and an inventory
management and like my how does it say
to get those powers like everyone talked
about like my mentors right I mean I'm
told I'm taking a snail's pace and I
think I am I'm now sitting comfortable
at like 12 13 hours and I'm playing on
hard mm-hmm goods I don't I'm more
confidently cuz you know you're you're
going back to your office to like always
dump your stuff if you haven't repaired
these recyclers because you need you
know it's part of the game with
resources but I'm now like going back
and I see a mimicking mean maybe I'm
just running by him which is kind of
eventually where you want to go just for
time sake but like it's not as bad it's
it's when I'm going into a new room that
I'm unsure like there are a couple parts
that are actually really neat where it's
like oh you just did well out and I
can't spoil it but numeri maybe there's
just a hump that I need to get over but
getting over that hump I haven't found
to be worthwhile yet mm-hmm I'm I keep
trying because I want to see the stuff
that you guys are so excited about yeah
but I don't I also don't feel like I'm
alone in no you're not no you're not no
I've definitely not I think it'll be a
divisive game I think it already is but
I didn't have I loved it right from the
beginning
I definitely the wrench combat I had to
crank my sensitivity just so like what a
minute you didn't you've been really
looking for this game like forever right
like right yeah yeah no I definitely
have but I just like arcane stuff so I
think I maybe I was super
into what they were trying to do with it
but I don't I don't feel as threatened
in the environment as a lot of people do
I especially well I have powers now I
have like you get something later on
that you can kind of it eliminates the
annoyance of the mimic for the most part
until kind of you get more powers and
stuff in like chipsets and I'm enjoying
the resource management and I'm enjoying
I am taking it very slowly and scouring
every room so once I find out that the
room is safe I'll actually take more
time I do that too but I'm saying the
rewards I'm seeing are boring emails
I've seen the same email I think it's
reductive to say the emails are the
reward whoa the emails are not the
reward that's so no that's so isn't the
narrative you guys were just here
telling me how that I'm saying I like
how the narrative is I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that's the reward that's
not acceptable words my mouth no what I
said you guys were literally just here
telling me all these little stories that
make it show interest that's not the
reward for life slogging through though
but but if but if you're playing this
game the way you want to you right if
that's the whole thing and I'm saying it
like the reward that I'm seeing in front
of me is this narrative it's what the
game puts up in front of you first and
foremost now I don't the narrative is
not the reward for me it's just adding
to it for me but I think I like the
comment I like how the power is what is
the reward for you that doesn't diminish
management the I'm not saying that the
emails are the singular thing I'm
fighting through these things for I'm
not having as many problems a lot of
people are I don't think it's just cuz I
was looking forward to the game I love
this game just because I'm liking the
combat as much problems with the French
combat I stop I look my whole point was
that you're saying you slow down and do
things I get to that point too and when
I do that the thing that I get for my
exploration isn't rewarding for me ya
know that's I know that's I'm saying
that's valid but I'm saying the emails
aren't my reward I'm saying the
resource-management the actual survival
aspects of the game the it's more about
getting the jump on enemies and figure
out what I want to do before they react
more than it is reacting to the enemies
and I think that's what once you have to
react to the enemies I think the combats
a little bit flawed but I feel that
between the resource management and the
difficulty and the actual the way it's
allowing me to prepare for this combat
with so much like resource management
and options where to put resources that
it's actually facilitating me being
prepared for fights more than it's
actually asked me to react when I have
more than a wrench and a glue gun maybe
that'll happen but yeah no I'm not being
motivated to get that yeah I don't I
even experience like a not learning
curve but like I didn't I really don't
want to say the word hump again
um but frenzy the the hot day the
barrier to enjoyment or what no that's
worse that's way worse hey mom I didn't
experience that because this is sort of
like the [ __ ] I do like like I like the
kind of narrative that they're setting
up and so for me it was immediately
interesting but I can 100% see like I
think you were right Mike that it's
something that's going to be divisive
because it gives you a lot of options
but if you don't like any of those
options there's nothing there for you
but if it's already something that you
like like if you if you want to unravel
a mystery of like scientists dying I'm
like yeah that is the good that's the
business like then I'm gonna have I'm
going to enjoy those even the slower
parts but if you if that if you don't
want to read the warning emails three
times which they mean I want like I
don't mind reading emails but like I
want to see the same one and every like
the first 12 computers I see that
definitely happens right that's gonna
say is that you get the same email
you're like alright cool what else um I
will say and like I hate I hate saying
this because I think a good game should
hook you right away that not every good
game but I'm saying if that does get
much better and you'll find new areas
that will reward an error so when you
you're saying you want over the hump
that makes more sense the emails up
front are kind of I'm so far from that
part of the game that I've kind of
forgot about that but it was pretty
redundant in lately they turn you off
cuz it's just like again you have really
boring emails but I think we were also
talking about where there are there's
also a distinction between the emails
and then like the conex and the books
that actually will freeze the game yeah
and that will that will be a nice like
calm collective moment or you don't have
to worry about shopping those are short
to me though they're short but they they
come in series so you find book 3 and
it's like oh cool I'm piecing together a
nice little like story that it seems to
be kind of like similar to what's going
on in the station whatever it is um but
to touch on I think the hop to really
clarify it again is is to a hub day is
to get to the alien powers and the game
is admin at saying like play your way
a and maybe that's the not the confusion
but the frustration with that idea is
that I knew at some point like you know
what there's all these side quests that
I have early on I'm gonna have to say no
to these right now
because I know what is ahead of me with
these powers and you get to those and
you unlock the more from the mimic or
yeah mimicking whatever it is especially
the kinetic blast yeah like you just you
want some of these things and that's
where the game's surprising to me and I
was able to like okay now I can kind of
breathe in feel confident in playing and
again I'm playing hard boat I like last
night I like literally had a different
opinion that going in like I'm gonna
have to dumb this down like these guys
are too intense and then I was like
getting those powers and I felt like I
was like so much more comfortable and I
was like getting in the rhythm of
inventory management and recycling I was
like having a good time toward the end
of the night I I want to go back and
play now without the powers I got maybe
that's because I'm loving the resource
management so much but I between like
weapon upgrade kits once you learn to
fabricate those and I just pump stuff
into my like silenced pistol and then
kind of learning just sticking to human
powers of science engineering security
leverage like moving objects yeah you
are growing those right buddies really
powerful by the way oh yeah I know I
keep forget about that yeah well if you
can successfully hit the friggin mimics
um you know what I also forgot to this
is random but like when I was saying I
couldn't get into that window I forgot
that you can use kinetic and that's why
I haven't you mentioned like oh these
powers being used like and like kind of
combo efforts like being a cup and then
launching yourself with kinect glass
right like yeah i don't even know if
anyone's done that yet in the office i
did I try try yeah it's a you mmm as a
cup no I don't think it did but you have
to see I set the kinetic blast and then
quickly mimic the cup and you'll be in
the kinetic blast launch but another
thing you get a kinetic pull later on
and you can't mimic things through glass
you have to actually have a direct line
to them I also really like the lore
behind how mimicking works at least in
this game it's not realistic you
actually swap with that object in a
quantum separate timeline so you exist
in a different timeline but your
consciousness stays in this one I don't
know
that sounds dumb but it's cool how do I
love stuff like that but I didn't have
any small enough object to get through
this little receptionist slot in an
office so I got back down look through
it pulled the cup to me and then put it
next to me and then mimicked it so I
could go through which that was really
cool you start combining them yeah yeah
I don't think the true enjoyment came
from this game until later on at least
up front I liked it became from a
survival game to more of an immersive
sim later on for me I I just I mean I
know I'm probably this isn't a comp like
a common opinion but I really love the
mundane like I love in any storytelling
like I love little mundane things that
you pick up that just kind of paint like
this is this is an interesting world
this is a surprising world but it's also
like people still had to send out
freaking emails about password security
and I just that like I'm enjoying it up
front because of stuff like that and I
know that's kind of weird and not a lot
of people like that sort of thing but I
really like staying grounded in some
semblance of reality especially when
something is so out there and when
you're making up explanations for
quantum whatever and you have all these
weird powers I like that there's still
stuff like that the reward of sifting
through the boring stuff yeah like I
actually like that I know that that is
not for everybody and so I wouldn't say
like oh yeah that's just this bright
spot in this game but I am enjoying that
in lie so I don't feel like there's
anything I have to get over to start
enjoying it and that really irritates me
when I when you feel like you have to
put in like if somebody's like Oh play
this JRPG it gets good 20 hours in I'm
like screw you I don't want like I don't
have 20 hours to be bored and so I
sympathize with that like I don't think
that's a I don't think the mundane is a
selling point but that is something that
I enjoy mm-hmm any final thoughts on
prey I'm gonna keep trying to play it um
I have faith that you know you guys know
that it's a good game I just I hope to
get there sooner rather than later yeah
Rob anything you want to keep playing it
uh yeah I really think you should keep
playing because now like there are
things already that I want to talk to
maybe you or later about cool
environmental
change ups you know like I would almost
want to say similar to soft top ahead
like two like towers and Zelda where you
think like oh this is getting tedious
like climbing a tower yet every tower
was like memorable you know what I mean
like you start seeing rooms in that same
respect and they're directly uh in
relation to a story of like what
happened in these rooms and with like
the aliens like as Mike said like
learning about like the physical G or
like the science behind these typhoons
is like increasingly getting more
rewarding as I play but yeah there was
this kind of Lowell to be said in the
beginning that I think we kind of all
agree on yeah one less why I do like
when I come back to a room and not even
remember what an MP seed in there but I
was like oh [ __ ] this is the room where
I screwed up that phantom by doing this
and then that mimic came out of nowhere
and then I don't know but yeah Tamar
Hussain is doing our official scored
review he it's all pretty much written
it'll go up soon soon keep it on
gamespot for that if you want further
thoughts and we got a few features up on
GameSpot about like tips and whatnot
things you might want to know before you
start playing if you haven't played if
you have started playing leave comments
on this video if it's on youtube after
the fact or a GameSpot yeah if like I'm
interjecting but yeah jean-luc made a
like what areas should you put neural
mods into and actually found that really
helpful oh yeah that like early neuro
mods guide especially if you're like me
and you get super paranoid about stuff
like that check that out it's time saver
where it's like alright like there are
all these later on progression unlocks
it's like you sifting and reading all
those can get a little like overwhelming
so he did a good video actually yeah
that was helpful and if you're enjoying
prey and haven't played dishonor
dishonor to you should go check those
out very different games but also by the
same creator so there are some
similarities from Arkane studios ah cool
I want to finish up with a few things
quick before we get to our last kind of
thing we're going to do today but yeah
so that giveaway that we mentioned
earlier is a Deus Ex mankind divided ps4
special edition that we have it'll be
later on the week once if you follow
GameSpot if you don't already onto
Twitter and then retweet the giveaway
tweet will pick a random winner later in
the week for ps4 in North America
only apologies to people outside there's
some legal stuff that we can't do
giveaways outside of that most of the
time yeah thanks to Richard Lee Eric
taejeon Luke in the back and one more
thing you might not know Marco Martinez
but he has been at GameSpot for a decade
now
doing like a ton of behind-the-scenes
stuff helping our social team and just
helping like kind of like does almost
everything at GameSpot but unfortunately
Friday this kind of Friday's his last
day so we figured we'd bring him on I
believe you have a lot of mic on right
yeah yeah cool so Marco figure we give
you a chance to come on lobby and say
farewell to everyone that you've been
helping these last 10 years that's crazy
because this iteration of like the lobby
is interesting watched like every
iteration like today on the spot on the
spot like just old chum been here
forever
yeah been longer than I think I've had
any job yeah I've been here like 10
years it's interesting seeing like the
site grow seeing like everybody grow
because I remember when all of you guys
were here so just like seeing where you
guys were and now it's like great to see
and it's gonna be nice to be a fan like
I really just I can read everything
watch everything nice it's like it's so
hard it's gonna be hard to leave but do
you want to talk about what you're doing
in general I don't know can you like
knock yeah it's a it's actually out of
the games industry which is surprising I
thought I was going to stay but it's a
company called nginx their web server
really out of the games so just running
their social media YouTube that kind of
stuff so it will be fun well
congratulations
thanks thanks sorry to see you go
obviously uh yeah man it's it's
super-sized do you go just because you
know you and gadje like I've just been
around just killing it and I feel like
more and more like just traits about
like what you actually do just get like
build upon and everyone you so reliable
I come III you I hope you found it you
guys are gonna kick out you guys are
gonna kick ass it I don't make sure that
nothing but yeah if you you'll be missed
yeah I mean a lot one more addition to
your guys a conversation on Wii U Wii
yeah Power Stone from did you guys
mention that at all now Power Stone from
making Vega no Dreamcast hey guys got to
check out Power Stone they have the
Power Stone collection for like four
bucks right now but Power Stone that
would be an awesome game on a Nintendo
switch if you haven't checked it out
player fighting game yeah it was like I
want to say the Dreamcast was before the
64 right then after after okay so maybe
some yeah Power Stone collection for
bucks on PSN so so we definitely check
that out that would be a great port it's
especially how you can connect easily on
the switch
yeah that game it's awesome we'll play
after play after this yeah I would say
speaking of a new time switch we're
gonna be playing a Mario Kart after work
tomorrow
yeah ah you're not gonna be too far away
though right yeah to us really awesome
to be torn I didn't lunch everything
third Thursday's yeah yeah also if
you're a GameSpot regular you probably
remember our rocket League tournament
last year two years last year marco was
my doubles partner and we still not
gotten revenge so yeah what we should
organize something last minute oh yeah
oh I don't know if I'll stream it we
probably won't we need revenge well
Mary's gone she was the one to beat us
yeah screw her that was not cool a
really good match but ah pleasure yeah
Marco thanks so much you will be missed
like Rob said you're always been
reliable as hell it's gonna be sad to
see you go but you know like I'm sure
you're on to better things with your
career and everything thanks guys
everybody for joining we thank you so
much for watching as always on YouTube
twitch or on GameSpot and we will see
you next week same time Wednesday is at
11 a.m. Pacific see you later
you
you